I complimented you backstage you have
terrific style you dress very well but I
noticed that recently you went through a
tracksuit phase I did and we actually
have the pictures to prove it
this is just in the last couple of
months yeah you I don't know what this
means but there you are I hope you're
not defecating but whatever you're just
in an airport there you are again
proudly showing off your tracksuit and
then here we have a third shot of you
and another tracksuit and I'm curious
what what happens to a man when he
decides I'm no longer going to dress I'm
jeanna adult like an adult right I'm
going to dress like someone who just ran
you know like participate in the
decathlon what what made you get to that
point you know I can't answer for every
man or woman who decides to wear track
suits but I can tell you that I
developed a case of what I like to call
that's where I was on a press tour for
call me by your name that went for 14
months
so we travel 14 months the movie
probably took comment to make like two
months to me six weeks six weeks six
weeks six weeks and then you send then
14 months talking about it
therein lies my issue with the press
tour so I woke up one day and I had
tracksuits with me because I thought I
might as well have some track suits and
I woke up in the morning and I thought
you know what
I now have senioritis like the senior in
school who has to go to class but they
hate their professors so they're like
I'm gonna show up in pajamas yeah my
equivalency was tracksuits and I thought
you know what if I'm gonna go jump
through these hoops and I'm gonna go
continue to talk about this movie that
I've talked about ad nauseam
I'm gonna be comfortable yeah I decided
to dress comfortably and I would also
like to take now thank you for setting
this up I would like to take this moment
on the show to officially announce my
retirement from tracksuits oh you're not
gonna wear them anymore I'm done I got
oversaturated and burned out on
tracksuit and now it's like I did this
thing we're on the press - I wore a
bunch of track suits and it got a lot
more traction than I was really
expecting it to I just thought I'd be
comfortable and then it became like a
thing of like farming Hammer whereas a
bunch of track suits
so then when I was like I'm done with
track suits they started pouring in
because this is like part of like the
whole actor thing that it's like kind of
I'm figuring out as I go if you're get
into something they'll send it to you
they say chief
free for free you got free tracksuits I
have 70 tracksuits in my that is not
even hyper I have 70 tracks braggart
mother you and I can share tracksuit I
would yes what do you want tracksuit yes
I do I like that track suits from I mean
everyone high level of course adidas
Fela sent me a bunch Hugo Boss Armani
are 20 minute honey makes a tracksuit
well hey what are you talking about
hound Ford offered to custom make me a
tracksuit and really the icing on the
cake
Oscar Meyer Weiner sent me attraction
the ultimate prize you know what I am
really long in the leg and so I can't
find when I get it with a theme it's
like 36 inch 36 for the same yeah yeah I
can't get Trax's and and now another guy
I will wear your track suits but only if
they've been pre worn by you I've never
washed a track suit yeah that makes
that's an erotic experience for me at
this stage of my life for sure having
wearing a track suit that's been against
your body and I wear it and then my wife
will so be boots to be attracted to me
she'll come to me you say there's
something so armie hammer ask about you
listen I mean if anybody here seen call
me by name I've sucked it on film I have
nothing against you wearing my track
suit like this is this is well within my
range
okay on film okay
how do you think soleio man your when
the cameras aren't rolling its got weird
really fast
you